[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
♪ ♪
>> Greg: WELCOME BACK TO THE
REAL HOLLYWOOD, HOLLYWOOD,
FLORIDA, WHERE THE FORECAST IS
LIBERAL TEARS, DEMOCRATS STILL
REELING OVER THE DOWNFALL OF
THEIR TOP DONOR AND FAVORITE
CRYPTO SCAMMER SAM BREGMAN
FREED, SEEN HERE LOOKING LIKE A
CROSS BETWEEN NANCY AND SLUG-O.
WENT TO THE SAME BARBER WHO CUT
FILL SELECTORS HERE.
THE FEDS ARE HOT ON HIS TRAIL
AND COULD EXTRADITE HIM FROM THE
BAHAMAS BACK TO THE U.S.
THEY PROBABLY WANT TO KNOW WHERE
$1.7 BILLION OF HIS CUSTOMERS
MONEY WENT.
PERSONALLY I WOULD START LOOKING
TO SEE IF THE CASH WOUND UP IN
NANCY PELOSI'S FREEZER ALONG
WITH HER ICE CREAM.
BECAUSE SAM BANKROLLED THE DEMS
TO 40 MILLION BUCKS, BUT THEY DO
NOT WANT TO TALK ABOUT THAT.
>> DO YOU THINK SOME LAWMAKERS
THAT GOT DONATIONS FROM FTX'S
FOUNDERS TO GIVE THAT MONEY
BACK?
>> I WANT TO GET INTO THAT BOTH
SIDES DEMOCRATS AND REPUBLICANS
HAVE RECEIVED DONATIONS,
THANK YOU.
>> Greg: SO JESSE, EVERYBODY
ELSE DOES IT, BUT WE ARE NOT
TALKING ABOUT BITCOIN, WE ARE
TALKING ABOUT REAL MONEY THAT
WAS TAKEN BY PEOPLE.
TAKEN FROM REAL PEOPLE.
>> Jesse: AND THEN PLOWED INTO
THE DEMOCRATIC SENATE CAMPAIGN,
SO HE BOUGHT THE SENATE FOR THE
DEMOCRATS AND HIS COMMUNITY
COMMITTING ALL SORTS OF
ATROCIOUS CRIMINAL CRIMES, AND
STILL SITTING IN THE BAHAMAS
TRYING TO RAISE MONEY, WHY IS
AND HE SHACKLED BY THE FBI?
IF HE WAS A REPUBLICAN DONOR HE
WOULD BE SITTING IN SOLITARY
CONFINEMENT RIGHT NOW.
SO THE DEMOCRATS ARE SO GREEDY.
IT DOES NOT MATTER WHERE THE
MONEY COMES FROM, DOES NOT
MATTER HOW IT HAS BEEN MADE OR
HOW DIRTY IT IS, THEY JUST SAY
GIVE IT, GIVE IT, GIVE IT TO ME.
AND THIS IS WHAT HAPPEN,
REMEMBER THEY CAN'T SEE ANY SORT
OF RED FLAGS, WOULD YOU GIVE
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS TO A GUY
WITH HAIR LIKE THAT?
I MEAN, HE LOOKS LIKE BOOGER
FROM REVENGE OF THE NERD.
HE DRESSES WORSE THAN FETTERMAN.
AND HAS ENOUGH POLYAMOROUS
RELATIONSHIP, HOW HAS HE NOT
BEEN METOOD, AND SHE GOES I
DON'T KNOW HOW TO DO ARITHMETIC
AND CRYPTO IS A BIG SCAM.
IT DOES NOT MAKE ANY SENSE TO
ME.
THEN HE GOES ON CHUCK TODD'S
SHOW AND IS SHAKING, PHYSICALLY
SHAKING, NOBODY GOES ON CHUCK
TODD'S SHOW AND SHAKES, IT'S THE
EASIEST INTERVIEW ON THE WORLD,
ALL OF THESE THINGS ARE POPPING
UP, SIGNING WITH BILL CLINTON.
ANY BUSINESSMAN ASSOCIATED WITH
BILL CLINTON IS OBVIOUSLY
SKETCHY.
THE FBI NEEDS TO GET THERE ASSES
IN GEAR, AND MAXINE, NO RELATION
NEEDS TO DO SOMETHING AND TAKE
CHARGE.
>> Greg: [LAUGHS]
I THOUGHT YOU GUYS WERE RELATED.
GLAD HE POINTED THAT OUT.
ALL RIGHT, HAROLD, I WILL TRY TO
MAKE THIS AS SHORT AS POSSIBLE,
BECAUSE I KNOW YOU HAVE A
HEADACHE.
[LAUGHTER]
>> Harold: FAKE NEWS.
>> Greg: [LAUGHS]
YES!
JESSE MAKES A GREAT POINT WHICH
IS RARE AND WE SHOULD GIVE THEM
CREDIT FOR THAT.
THIS GUY IS WAY, WAY TOO
UNATTRACTIVE TO BE A
BILLIONAIRE.
BECAUSE YOU FIX EVERYTHING,
RIGHT?
SO CLEARLY HE DOES NOT HAVE THE
MONEY, AND IF YOU ARE MEETING
HIM HE WOULD BE LIKE NO WAY THIS
20-YEAR-OLD HAS A BILLION
DOLLARS, YOU WOULD AT LEAST HAVE
A DECENT BARBER.
WHY ARE DEMOCRATS SO STUPID,
HAROLD?
THAT'S WHAT I'M SAYING.
>> Harold: THE INVESTIGATION
THE CONGRESS IS GOING TO PURSUE
IN THIS MATTER IS THE FIRST TIME
THAT MAXINE WATERS' SHARE OF THE
COMMITTEE UP UNTIL JANUARY IN
THE RANKING MEMBER WHO WILL BE
THE CHAIRMAN, THE GUY NAMED
PATRICK MANAHAN NEARY IS THE
THEY HAVE AGREED AND WILL HOLD
THE HEARING AND DO IT JOINTLY.
NUMBER ONE, NUMBER TWO, ANYONE
THAT RECEIVED ANY CONTRIBUTIONS
FROM I CAN'T EVEN PRONOUNCE THE
YOUNG MAN'S NAME.
>> Greg: I UNDERSTAND, ROUGH
NIGHT.
SPEAK TO ANYONE THAT RECEIVED A
DONATION MIGHT'VE BEEN 3-1
DEMOCRATS, BUT REPUBLICANS GOT
IT TOO, THEY SHOULD ALL GIVE
THEIR MONEY BACK.
I DON'T THINK YOU HOLD A
POLITICIAN ACCOUNTABLE FOR
SOMETHING HE OR SHE DID NOT
KNOW, YOU MAY NOT LIKE HIS
BUSINESS, HE WOULD NOT GO INTO
THAT BUSINESS, BUT YOU CAN'T --
IT'S A LEGAL BUSINESS THAT THAT
GUY WAS IN.
NUMBER THREE, THEY SHOULD
REGULATE THIS.
THEY SHOULD REGULATE THE SPACE.
AND YOU AND I KNOW THAT
SOMETIMES YOU CAN REGULATE A
SPACE, BUT IF A PERSON IS JUST
REALLY BAD AND THE TERRIBLE
HUMAN BEING, I DON'T KNOW IF
THIS GENTLEMAN IS, BUT IF THEY
ARE REALLY BAD, SOMETIMES YOU
CAN EVEN CORRECT LAWS TO MAKE IT
RIGHT.
THEY SHOULD REGULATE THIS AND BE
TRANSPARENT ABOUT IT AND I HOPE
THAT IT IS BIPARTISAN, THAT WAY
PEOPLE HAVE TRUST IN THE LAW
WHEN IT GETS DONE.
[LAUGHTER]
>> Greg: I THINK I HEARD AN
AUDIBLE SIGH FROM THE JUDGE.
IT'S BEYOND BIPARTISAN, FIRST OF
ALL, ANYTHING THAT COMES OUT OF
THE HOUSE, THE SENATE ISN'T
GOING TO PASS, AND IF THEY DO,
THE PRESIDENT ISN'T GOING TO
SIGN IT.
THEY ARE NOT GOING TO ALLOW ANY
OF US TO LOOK LIKE WE HAVE
ANYTHING POSITIVE GOING THROUGH
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
THAT IS NUMBER ONE TREND
NUMBER 2, "THE NEW YORK TIMES"
RUNS AN ARTICLE ABOUT SAM
BREGMAN FREED, WHATEVER -- HE IS
FRIED.
>> Harold: YOU CAN'T PRONOUNCE
HIS NAME EITHER.
>> Judge Jeanine: AND I WAS
NOT OUT WITH YOU LAST NIGHT.
[LAUGHTER]
AND THEY SAY, WELL, THIS GUY YOU
MAY BE IN OVER HIS HEAD, HE
SEEMS LIKE A NICE ENOUGH SMART
KID, ALL OF THE RIGHT THINGS
GOING ON, "THE WASHINGTON POST"
IS IN TEARS.
THEY ARE SAYING OH, MY GOD, THE
GUY WAS TRYING TO PREVENT THE
NEXT PANDEMIC.
SO I LOOK UP HOW IS HE TRYING TO
PREVENT THE NEXT PANDEMIC?
BY SUPPORTING DEMOCRATS WHO SAY
THEY WANT TO PREVENT THE NEXT
PANDEMIC.
IT'S LIKE 80% OF THE MONEY WENT
TO DEMOCRATS, IT'S NOT GOING TO
REPUBLICANS, IF YOU GIVE IT TO
REPUBLICANS WHO SAY THAT IT IS
BIPARTISAN.
LET ME TELL YOU ONE MORE THING,
HE IS A LIAR.
HE SAYS HE IS A VEGAN AND HE
LOOKS LIKE THIS --
OKAY?
AND FINALLY, LET ME JUST SAY,
THE GAIA SHOULD HAVE BEEN
EXTRADITED ALREADY.
WE HAVE AN EXTRADITION TREATY
WITH THE BAHAMAS, LOCK HIM UP,
MOVE THEM IN.
THAT IS OUR JERK, OUR JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT.
>> Greg: I THINK YOU MIGHT
AGREE WITH ME THAT WE NEED LESS
VIRTUE SIGNALING A MORE VIRTUE.
>> Dana: YES, WE DO, THAT'S A
GOOD IDEA.
>> Greg: HAROLD SAID THAT TO
ME IN THE BATHROOM.
IT'S BEEN ON LAST NIGHT?
>> Dana: LAST NIGHT.
THAT WAS SOME SIGNALING YOU ALL
WERE DOING LAST NIGHT.
>> Greg: HE SIGNALED A LOT OF
SHOTS.
>> Dana: I GUESS SO.
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT SAM BANK
MEN FREE FRIED SAID THAT HE WAS
DONATING THIS MONEY AND HE WOULD
DO IT TO LIBERAL CAUSES, RIGHTS,
AND THAT AN EXCHANGE WITH A
REPORTER FROM BOX NEWS THAT HE
DID IT BECAUSE IT GAVE HIM AS
YOU USED TO CALL IT THE SCANDAL.
DO YOU REMEMBER THAT?
THE GLOBAL INITIATIVE.
>> Greg: YOU PUT EVERYTHING IN
THAT CLIMATE CHANGE NOBODY COMES
AFTER YOUR PHILANDERING OR
EVERYTHING, HUNTER DID THAT AND
EVERYTHING.
I SHOULD DO THAT.
WHY DIDN'T I THINK OF THAT, MY
LIFE WOULD BE SO MUCH BETTER.
>> Dana: ANY WAY I WAS
THINKING THAT HE REALLY DID THAT
AND IT EXPOSES HIM, BUT THESE
THINGS HAPPEN ALL THE TIME.
IF YOU WOULD NOT INVEST YOUR
MOTHER'S MONEY IN A COMPANY,
THEN THINK TWICE BEFORE YO